TH WHI HOU WORNGOVERTIME
TO CONVINC AMECANSHAT
CO-HIGSCHO G PRICE
E ALADIR PUTIS ULT.>>OU M HAVE
VLADIMIRPUTI  WI   .
COMPIE I ISN THEIL
APPROVEDUNED PMITS THA OIL
>> WT DOU MEF TT . INT
THIS INFTIONAS GNGNELL DR EANI,
NOBODY WTS T GONTHE
BLAH. STUFF ISN ABLE BLA
THROBL HAVING A DOCT I
CHGE IN TSIND  OEALS
IF THE CONQUENS MCH THEIR DERES
WEEE THA NO ES.
IST IT WEI THAHE WHITEHOE SMSES
ICESIT BECSE THEWANT HIGR
OIL PRISELL BOREHIS WAR
STARD A PUT INVED T
RAE.
ABOU IT. Y D'T CAR
MORE. Y WA USO PAY
EY WT U TOEEL PNT E
WITHWINDLLS IN BACKAT EORAS USA
WE AEMINDED J BID ISN
INSI WEHERVE.
WHOEVE IS IHE ROO WH HIM,
FALEFTAN-LEFTCADEMICSRE A RM O
KING THEM D WHAVER THEY
WA.
RIG BORE THETA OF E
UNIONEALKED AUTIDEN
ADNISTRATI ACCPLHMEN
FUEL WLNERILITIES.HE'S WTE SAIO
IANTOU T LOO IN MY
ES.
UARANTEE U, I GRAEE Y
>> NBEO, HOLNG THEM R
AT TY VEDONE
E WL DOUBL OSHE WI.
OR A OTH FSIL FUELROAL
>> NOWHEY E LI,HERERE
L TSEEASE --
CRAZ BETTERRILL BEFE WEEN YO
YOU'RE ING  BLA PUN,
NE.
IT?T AREOU GNG TO DOBOUT
YOU' STILL N DOINYTHG
THEYREUST FINGER INTI.
NALD REAN SAID D, WRE
GOINTO PPUR O OND H
T THEAUDI TUMP L.
TH ALMTANKRT TOVIET
UNIO
DEHE SAUHAPP
THEMF. ITS BACKWARD MSING
THIN ABO THATTALANBU HEON'TAL T.
EY AED HDAY,HY WON'T
YOU EVENAVENY OF TSE OIL
EXECUTES T THE WHI HOU
FOR TE OISSTS, TAL AUT
FOR THEPEOP. ESETTE
SH GO,WE, WE D'T HE
THATNG ON TCHEDEOR
WE, YOU SULDECAUOU
YS HE T WKOGETHERITH
THE PEOP.
L I LIK FO.
CANNOT SVIVEITHO L. T SURVI- AR
THEYEED TOET THE A
TOGEER.
HERIVE THESE MCLEARS THAI ELECI
GET TRIBL MES T THEMILE
THEN YOUEE THE OITH Y ALL HAVEO.
MASKS.>>L GOR DID AT.
HIGHERHAN ERYBODY SE'S
TORING IRANAC T THETABLHEY WANT
TH WT TT, OMARAN
INSTEAD  DEANG WITHHE
SAUD, WREEANG WHIRAN.
ANDE'RE DEALING WIT INITH
SANCONING SSIA B NOWE
IRANHEMT TH TABLE WH
TO, TS IS LE IF YOU ND
A BASITT, RIGH AND YOUHA A 15-Y
N BY S, B YOU SAY,
DOT WA MYAUGHR T
BYIT,'M GNG T GO
NEXTOOR,UT NT-DOOR IS
NVTEDURDER AND TUY
THATENG TO KL YTOO, B
I'LL SEE --
>> HE' NICE
>> HE'S NIC GU
THAT WT TH AREING.
OURNEMYO PUT US INURCH
>>DANA THAAS THE FIR
ALOGY.
WEOVEHE ANAGY ANDHE
BASITTER.
WELLNE.
I DN'T OW Y WERE
PUTI THE OIL COMPIES,R J
DEN.
PARTAN DIDE. IKSHE
I NER PARCULAY HRDIL
FAT CAT WHOREEAPINGECOR
PROFS BNG - VIRAL STOLEAS EQUTL
RE.
THINK TEMOCTS
PRIC TOAKE THE CNT GGRN I PREPT
SD I -
>>ELIEVE YR EA.
I BIEVEHAT THE O
MPANIESREAKIN RECOR
>> FOLLO ITLL THEAY TO IRA
DUSSI AND MBE VENEELA.
TH'S